so you don't care about marriage
I got the shot
okay how does that make you feel
[Music]
hey how are you
over there
look at his face never mind I don't I
don't come inside I know I said I fixed
her earlier I don't go outside his hand
he's like what is this
it's mine it's for love it's for love
did you make this no it's a crystal that
comes from the earth it comes from from
the Earth
that's what's up is this is this is it
like a mood stone is it going to change
colors depending upon my mood no no so
if you set your intention on it it's a
rose quartz so if you set your intention
that you want for love yeah put it by
your bed
so I put this up under my bed not under
your bed well you can put it under your
bed if you want but right beside your
bed on your bedside table yeah
what y'all think you're gonna do with
that Christmas
this is a premium Auntie right here this
is one one top two yeah yeah it's funny
when she came and he was smiling he just
looks confused no she on his ass
right now she's doing some spells on him
this might get real weird fast like
let's go back you've got to set your
intention on it so I gotta set my
attention on it all right I'm gonna put
it by my best on but my friends might
beat me up if you see this no I didn't
next door really intelligent book you
can put the book so they put the book
there and then no one will see it but
the moonstone in the book The Rose
Quartz so my friends don't beat me up
yeah for it okay I'm gonna do that Mama
what's your name Naomi Naomi MTR it's a
pleasure to make it are you shaking girl
listen don't be nervous
oh no give me the other one
don't be doing a risk girl all right I
don't bite I bleed red just like
everybody else all right we're gonna
make you comfortable here today you
understand me all right okay cool smooth
hands you work a computer job
um I do I do recruitment for children
residential children oh I know I'm good
and I also write on the right side
you're a writer I hate writing
well I I respect it I like creating
stories okay so I like the creative
writing yeah I'm I'm writing an erotic
romance
neurotic or erotic
okay let's let's get in there especially
based on unconditional love really like
the whole premise is like the different
types of relationships that people tend
to go through and then at the end they
find each other and because it's always
written from a male's perspective and a
female's perspective and so who's the
audience
females
because that's why I've written it from
a male's perspective as well so like do
you think Men read erotic novels no but
a woman will be able to see a male's
perspective Within the book so nothing
is working
all right but I may all be able to see
yeah the woman will be able to while
she's reading it and be able to see the
male's perspective throughout his
relationships that he goes through as
well and then when they find
unconditional love the how a man
approaches it the love is going to be
very different to how the woman does
within the book so then it's not just a
woman's perspective throughout the whole
book and then you know so but that just
sounds like a novel what's the erotic
part of it well the sex
oh okay is this like the 50 Shades of
Gray sex or is this like the normal you
know what I mean
like to explore a lot more does that
mean that you're a very sexual person
um well sexual energy is Creative Energy
the creation of everything it's how we
create babies it's how we create our
artistic so it's the Kundalini energy so
do yoga I do do yoga a tantric
practitioner as well are you a free
spirit
did you see my ass oh
no use a Buddhist
you from
accent or Heritage like Heritage some
half Nigerian half British okay but you
lived in London the entire time no I
grew up in the Lake District in the what
so where the hills and the lakes are so
in the United Kingdom yeah but you grew
up in the rural places yeah did you own
a pony I did do horse riding wow so like
super rural yeah yeah there's just cows
and like the whole town was one mile I
just did a discussion with a young lady
that would have wanted me to kill cows
for her
yeah she's she's a little bit too
excuse me ma'am
you wouldn't kill a cow for me
um here's the thing if we if we needed
to eat
here's the thing is I feel like that's
illegal I can't just go around
[Laughter]
do you know what the issue is men
nowadays are not like manly men like
they'd be too scared to do that to eat
to kill a cat I don't need a man to kill
a cow grocery store
I think they're logical it's like why
would I kill a cow and I could just go
and buy it but what's happening soon is
people are going to have to be a lot
more self-sufficient because the
government are going to start like
rationing us
I wish I knew more
we kill cows in Nigeria all right there
you go girl
when are they gonna take the food away
from us what is this happening so they
have a thing called agenda 2030 they're
calling it The New World Order and what
they're planning on doing is basically
they said to us you're going to own
nothing and be happy by day I mean the
World Health Organization this sounds
like Y2K like I'm older so no no no girl
like this sounds like Y2K I get did you
believe in this and I get this but like
all throughout history we've had famines
we've had I mean atrocities in this
world and I know this is a big deal to
you but if you look in the U.S I like to
bring up like like there are real
historical atrocities that actually
happen that people allow government
systems allowed if anything people who
have actually been oppressed should have
more to worry about the government than
people are a place of privilege like I
get what you're saying but like ease up
a little bit it's just so it's so
intense
and the rest of us are just stupid it's
not me it's not me making this up though
okay it's not Me Maybe right you're
right in 10 years time if you watch this
video back you'll see it's like it'll be
like a like a prophecy and you you said
the guy that like you learned you
learned a lot of it you learned that you
love right give me the Powerball numbers
because I'm ready to listen you want the
Powerball I
I get it girl but do you have another
dimension to yourself other than just
kind of talking about this the whole
time and I'm not saying it's a criticism
but it's just so forceful it's so like
you're putting all of this on everybody
and this is not what the Forum is I'm
warning people about it before it
happens so that that is important to me
so what we need to do prepare yourselves
become more self-sufficient start
growing your own food
start living away from places which are
completely you know controlled by the
government
[Laughter]
have you killed a cow a chicken because
I know women who live on farms who have
yeah cool I I have my family has thumbs
I haven't done it but I would if I was
in it how come you haven't done it yet
because I don't live there but why don't
you live there because you said that
we're supposed to but aren't you
supposed to prepare like you should be
the leader and you're showing us where
to go why are you still here in this
environment when it happened well why
not start now you just told us you gotta
let her talk go ahead because I'm
warning people now that's why so we're
in a place right like in in London
there's a lot of people who need to hear
this because they're completely cut off
from reality they they're living in
they're living in this delusion and
they're just having to like you know go
to the supermarket to get all their food
which when when that's taken away from
us when they start just delivering
rations to us you're not going to be
able to you know live like that anymore
you're gonna live like a government
slave basically oh government slave
people have been slaves throughout
history and in the U.S we've lived
already I can't just go around killing
yes you had your own if we had our own
farm and I'm I'm a city boy I'm from New
York I don't I don't do Farms together
no we can we can lie on the grass for
sure but if I see bugs bigger than my
finger we're getting up out of the grass
and my ratchet is coming out right we're
going to be shooting bugs right next to
each other okay I mean yeah listen let
me let me be frank I love nature I love
um it's dope for me to like turn off the
cell phones leave them you know
especially myself because I work on the
internet so I'm constantly inundated
with messages I'm constantly inundated
with email like DMS I'm constantly
inundated and I have a bit of decision
fatigue right where you just get tired
from just making decisions right so like
to me it'll be dope to like a date for
example you know we turn off the cell
phones and we just go out somewhere and
go stargazing or something like that
yeah I know you bang with that 100 I've
got a question
um what does once you've got to a
certain age what does it look like for
you in retirement how old are you by the
way I'm 36 36. okay 36 you don't know
36. you age agree just like me I'm 37.
no no I asked before again oh before you
got here yeah oh so you don't like the
young boy
so if I was 27 you wouldn't have came up
here but you heard 37 you're like all
right all right
transitional phase for men and women and
so that seven years of growth that was
six years of growth
um in knowing who you are and what you
are and where we're going and all those
things for you to be able to lead
is very much solidified I think when you
get to your age yeah the um you know
it's crazy when you know I get
um young men wanting to consult with me
and at 25 they feel like their life is
over and I'm just like brother it's just
started it's just and it gets better
later it gets better later but you know
oftentimes it could be the opposite for
women yeah you know it can be the
opposite that they can kind of see it as
the end of the road because of you know
the geriatric pregnancy which is
you got a young Moon I mean the body
count is is admirable yeah
[Laughter]
oh and that's it folks
he was going waiting and then he said uh
no no it's like the opposite of when she
said 21.
[Laughter]
you just look very happy yeah
okay I've got 19 year old daughter
and a 10 year old boy
same father no were you married I was no
I wasn't married to my son's father that
I was engaged we were both in the
military together the son is the 10 year
old yeah yeah so wait I have a question
this is a male perspective right so
two kids do they have the same father is
that important for guys like perspective
wise do y'all care about that okay yeah
I thought that was interesting yeah it's
a baby daddy anyway it doesn't matter if
they were married or not
no American not to me American guys are
different okay what about Nigeria guys
what do you guys think yeah definitely
myself it matters okay
it depends on the situation anyway I
mean I've heard I've heard it's like if
a guy like why would a guy marry you if
you didn't require a marriage like for a
kid from the last guy so it's like he
basically you're asking the next guy to
pay a high higher price for a used
product so so it's like if you're saying
yeah you have to marry me to get a child
but Tom Dick and Harry didn't
but it's not it's not so much that it
matters to us individually it's more
like Africans who are more family
orientated so even we take opinions from
our family members and we want our woman
to fit in with the family so if she's
not accepted there's just going to be a
tough relationship so they wouldn't
accept that the fact that she had two
kids not unmarried and things like that
under no circumstances we don't care
about her character she's a good person
no no it depends it also depends on the
situation what if he was rich because
Africans like money what if she had
money no okay
men don't that's interesting men do not
care at all how much money you make
African cultures they do they even they
want you if they come from stature they
want their woman that their son is
dating to come from stature too
that your woman has to come from stature
if you come from Saturday maybe like a
class class does she have to make money
or does her family have the baby but she
doesn't have yeah but but it's more of a
class thing I think rather than
there's a lot of countries that are
yeah like a girl could be from a lower
class and make money but it doesn't make
her High
classes cardi B is very successful yeah
it's more of a joining to get our
families done individuals yeah
on the west is more selfish yeah girl we
all for one okay at 16 okay well 10 days
from my 17th birthday I had her okay and
then I joined the military and then I
met my son's dad in Iraq
and then you in the military yeah
physically oh you got a background
let me ask you a slightly weird question
has the 19 year old daughter read the
erotic books no no no no no you keep
that away yeah why'd you gonna know well
the question that I asked I did a um
live stream with sister Shah razada ali
um about a year and a half ago two years
ago you may or may not be familiar with
her
um and one of the things that she said
is is that we have to protect young
people from premature sexual arousal and
I think in modern times today when you
can go on something like an app like
Twitter and easily like back in my day
finding some naked bodies you had to go
through some hoops right you know what
I'm saying like we had like the cable
boxes where you hit on that one station
and it was kind of like it was like wavy
and you can kind of make out like a
half corner on semi-circle of a teddy
you know what I'm saying you can kind of
make it out and you just you know what
I'm saying but every like 12 and a half
minutes you might be able that was back
in my day you know what I'm saying but
nowadays you go right up on Twitter
you can see and I think it's deranging a
lot of these young people I think they
are
perception but that's too early I will
go and say that a lot of young boys from
our generation would have just watched
cassette players with uh DVDs of Pawn
and palm magazines and stuff and usually
it's older cousins that I've when I'm
listening to people men talk about their
first sexual experience in terms of
watching it so is that older cousin that
exposed them to it and then it gives
them a completely warped perception of
what sex is meant to look like yeah um
and that's why I say that I think that
um
women young women should talk be taught
how to communicate effectively with
their Partners so that they can have a
healthy sex life with their partner and
young men should also
do the same like communication is so
lost because we're all just pretending
that it's some performance and like it's
a journey not a rush to the Finish Line
um let me ask you another question there
might be slightly personal that's my
question
I'm sorry I missed the question
um what does retirement look like for
you so what do you once you don't have
to do all of your work and stuff like
that what does it look like for you
because obviously past that point your
children are now older it's then just us
two what does that look like I'm always
going to want to deliver value
as a young kid one thing that my father
always used to tell me was that
I'm sacrificing components and degrees
in my life to make sure that you become
a better version of me
and I think that I lead forward with
that that
when I have the time and truth be told
like that's a large component of the
reason why I don't have kids now is
because
I want to build a foundation for myself
incredible enough where I can dedicate
as much time energy and effort to my
legacy that I create as far as them
going into the future so for me what I
create into the future is going to be a
main purpose driver at the same time I'm
trying to do things in my life right now
where I can have all of my time because
when I consider what's most important it
is your time as well as your health yeah
right your time your health and your
purpose so I think that
um
I can sit well within having
the maximum amount of time to do
whatever the hell that I want and what's
that whatever and whatever the hell that
I want is whatever the hell that I want
so if if in March I want to go and take
a trip down to Puerto Rico and stay for
a month then I want to do that if then
the next month I want to go back to the
States you know pay bills for a little
while then I can do that next month
after that if I want to go to Key Largo
then I can just do that and just live a
lifestyle of abundance without having to
worry about you know simplicities within
life and you know I got a pretty decent
start with that within my life so you
know time will tell what are the top
I like
I like him he's thinking could I be a
step daddy
step down
is how they get you they give you a
crystal and be like you know what forget
about my baby daddy
don't ask questions I appreciate that
um
there's a talking space within the
sector
um and feel free to if this makes you
feel uncomfortable feel free not to
answer this there's a talking space
within the sector that oftentimes that
um women with daughters often compete
with those daughters do you think that's
a real thing from your experience having
an adult age daughter that there's
perhaps a competition that might happen
between you guys
um because men your age might also be
looking at a 19 20 21 year old as well
yeah I would
very careful over who I brought into my
home for a start
um
I don't see competition
um I want her to be 10 times better than
I have ever been and ever could be
because she's my 1.0 right she's an
extension of me but she's an amazing
human being in her own right so I think
for it's a big competition I feel that
then that's from not from a place of
unconditional love and I unconditionally
love her so I couldn't ever see myself
competing with like there's no
competition like
there's yeah that's never even hooked
into my mind but I do see it in other
people
so for you personally no but out you you
understand what it is that I'm saying
yeah yeah and it's the same with um
young men and their fathers I think you
think so when it comes to like their
relationship with their mother it's like
I when they're younger it's like I want
to emulate
that of my father so it's then a
competition like I wanna
I see what you're saying yeah in a sense
that when a man and a woman get married
oftentimes the man thinks that he's
going to maintain priority yeah but when
the woman has this has children the man
will find out that he is not a top dog
boy because boys boys mama's boy like
completely boys will yeah and the boy
will always be so protective over the
mother so yeah
um yeah I think that I see where women
can feel like I'm not that old either so
like my daughter we're quite like when
we're walking down the street people
think we're sisters so I think when
women start to lose their beauty and
like start to look old and feel old they
then start to I guess feel maybe a
little bit jealous of their daughter be
true beauty and their youth and all of
the things that they maybe could have
done and hadn't done and these things
but I I don't feel that way so so
daughter at 16 has now 19 son at ten you
don't like condoms
work for my body except the natural way
so I have to like like track my cycle
whereas obviously at 16 I wasn't doing
that but I was on the Depo injection so
they say you don't need to um
but think about that you would get
pregnant even if the condom split and so
I was actually in the military when I
found out I was pregnant with my
daughter I didn't know that I was
pregnant because I'd had a period and
all these things and so it wasn't
necessarily I don't like condoms it was
just I'm extremely fertile
I'm just very embed
my body is designed it just beats the
BCS all 30 forms above control you've
met your match what up
all right
y'all understand
scary contact come on my brother Jesus
yeah turn it to orange or some I
didn't know there was 34 what injection
that's the pills it's about 30 forms of
contraception yeah between the depos
between condoms obviously I use condoms
and stuff but I'm not about wait a
minute obviously I'm saying obviously
how's that obvious because my son's my
son was planned
oh because I was with myself yeah I was
with my son
no no my daughter I had she definitely
okay so even though I say she wasn't
planned from the age of three my I was
raised by a single mother so I've always
said that
she programmed me to have this mindset
that you don't need a man yeah so from
the age of three my Mantra was that I
was going to be a single mum with a
little girl called Aisha so I kind of
manifested that situation wild where my
mum told me that story I'm like did you
not think to correct that story mum no
no where you told your mom this story
now my mom told me this story wait
wait your mother you buy it who is she
we need to write a goddamn Starbucks I
need to interview her immediately
why would she do some like that
I think
I've got two guys it's been amazing
guys listen to me there's so many more
questions that I need to ask her okay
she just might get invited back to the
next round just so I can keep on asking
questions I am so confused I am
disturbed I am perturbed that's it's
just so crazy these mothers are ruining
these children did their child's lives
like excuse me
what she ideated or or idealized being a
single mother and the mother didn't
correct it
excuse me it makes me feel like
in order to be a parent in order for you
to get down and greasy you need to take
a test like we gotta put we gotta put
you to through parental tests the same
way before you start driving we put to
do a car test before you start can we
got to put you through a goddamn parent
test because for God damn you know what
I'm saying and it's so crazy is that
because she's 36 right she's 36 two kids
two different fathers
um and still looking for love and his
things that like she gave me the move
that you know I'm starting to feel all
all wavy I feel in love already with the
with the mood thing you know I'm serious
about about almost getting beat up
though come on now like like my boys see
this they go They're gonna
throw it across the room at my head
that's the first thing ow that hurt
they're gonna come up they're gonna beat
the softness they're gonna beat the
astrology up out of me they're gonna
beat the god the everything you know
what I'm saying and I expect them to do
that hold me accountable this what is
what the the mood Crystal Rock
Earth spinning moon circle sign all
of that
I don't know she lives in her truth
though at the end of the day I thought
that she was a sweetheart outside of the
dating situation I I you know I feel
like we would actually you know get
along you know what I'm saying she's a
free spirit you always got to keep a
good free spirit in your pocket you
understand what I'm saying just in case
just in case this you know what I'm
saying you need to get real in these
streets the free spirits will come
through like yo what's up all right but
for like serious dating which is what
I'm actually looking for guys seriously
but serious dated
plus you're sweetheart all right are you
a virgin
[Music]
um
wait no no no no no y'all have
everything that I don't need and not
providing anything that I do need what's
up with